partez pour une immersion dans la
recherche spatiale
le cnrs organisme national
multidisciplinaire qui couvre tous les
domaines scientifiques fête ses 80 ans
l'exposition face à l'univers s'est
déroulée à gif-sur-yvette dans le
château du cnrs acquis en 1946 soit neuf
ans après la création du centre national
des recherches scientifiques
cette exposition est inédite parce
qu'elle elle rassemble une trentaine
d'instruments 30 instruments spatiaux
qui ont été développés dans les
laboratoires franciliens
le public pouvait échanger avec 75
astrophysiciens planétologues et
ingénieurs en instrumentation spatiale
les instruments d'exploration des
planètes étaient visibles ainsi que leur
évolution dans le temps
comme cet instrument spatiale microméga
à un microscope qui est le petit fils de
mes gars ces instruments servent à faire
donc une image d'une surface planétaire
d'un échantillon à toutes les couleurs
de la lumière dans un domaine spectral
de du visible et de l'infrarouge
d'autres instruments spatiaux sur
lesquels les chercheurs ont travaillé
qui ont fait le succès de missions
spatiales telles que vénus express ou
encore aux états étaient présentes et
2019 marque aussi les 50 ans du premier
pas de l'homme sur la lune
les conférences et expositions
rencontres ont rassemblé toutes les
générations des animations en réalité
virtuelle avec la particularité d'avoir
été réalisé à partir de véritables
d'image collectés lors de missions
spatiales et un escape game à bord d'une
navette spatiale était proposé aux
visiteurs ils sont venus en nombre au
désespoir de certains on parle du coup
un peu un peu déçu mais beaucoup
beaucoup de monde ça qu'on s'attendait
pas à ce qu'ils aient autant de monde
mais ça avait l'air ça va être
intéressant
c'est assez dommage 1700 personnes ont
fait le déplacement pour découvrir face
à l'univers